друзі Всіх вітаю разом з Петром
Порошенком Ми сьогодні мали низку
зустріч з нашими колегами депутатами
британського парламенту зокрема з
багаторічним лідером групи дружби
британського парламенту з української
Верховною Радою Джоном і ми подякували
йому за нову ініціативу створення такої
групи друзів консерваторів з Україною
Звичайно це дуже сприятиме активізації
між парламентсько діалогу і також ми
зустрічалися з депутатом британського
парламенту Робіна Міллера під час цих
зустрічей акцентували увагу на кількох
дуже важливих питаннях перше Україні
потрібно більше зброї більше зброї саме
натівського зразку більш такої дальності
дії для того щоб ми мали ефективний
Контрнаступ і оцей от переваги такі
військові щоби ця зброя була дальністю
більше трьох тисяч кілометрів Це
допоможе нашим збройним силам України і
очевидно що британський парламент може
про це говорили із урядовцями
Британського уряду але парламент
відіграє дуже важливу роль наданні
Україні нової зброї друге питання - це
підтримка України на шляху до НАТО
закликали в рамках парламентської
асамблеї НАТО підтримати спеціальну
заяву щодо початку таких переговорів
України щодо нашого членства в НАТО
третє акцентували особливу увагу на
незаконній анексії українських територій
на спробі крадіжки Путіним не більше
атомної електростанції запорізької АЕС
Очевидно це потребує більш жорсткої
реакції світу Ми дякуємо британцям за
лідерство щодо санкції тиску на
російську федерацію Ну але очевидно цей
тиск має бути більш потужним а закликали
не пускати до Британії до так само до
Європи всіх цих тікачів від мобілізації
Нехай протестують в Росії нехай
відкривають рота і починають
протестувати проти війни проти
загарбницької політики Путіна а не бути
поза війною відповідно і жити в
цивілізованому світі
пропагуючи підтримуючи війну також дуже
важлива програми Британського уряду по
реабілітації українських
військовопоранених і реабілітації
поранених цивільних і навчання наших
військових от це навчання вже показує
дуже перспективні такі позитивні
практичні результати і важливо щоб ці
програми проекти навчання українських
військовослужбовців в країнах НАТО
зокрема великі Британії вона тут займає
лідерську позицію були активізовані ми
закликали вже зараз навчати українських
пілотів за стандартами НАТО працювати на
літаках натівських тому що рано чи пізно
ну країни наші партнери такі будуть
змушені надати ми в це впевнені в цьому
і працюємо над цим Україні не тільки
зброю не тільки важку техніку а й літаки
а й системи ппу посилені це потрібно
Тому що Путін не припиняє своє
агресивної політики Ну і нас запитували
наше британські партнери як ми ставимося
до цих блін
не депутатів а спікера держдуми
Російської Федерації пані Матвієнко що
Росія готова до переговорів знаєте Росія
говорить про те що вона готова до
переговорів з 24 лютого спочатку
повномасштабно вторгнення питання Тільки
в тому що Росія під переговорами бачить
українську капітуляцію наполягаючи на
цих своїх пунктах по так званому
демілітаризації України де
націоналізації де де націоналізації і
інших там де але ми хочемо сказати що
найкраще переговори з Росією будуть
зброй Власне вони допомагають нашій
дипломатії наші ніж парламентські
дипломатії і ми за переговори ЗСУ і
всіма силами допоможемо ЗСУ цим таким
конструктивним і дуже фаховим
переговором з армією агресорів вбивці і
окупантів тому просимо більше зброї
більше техніки посилення санкцій проти
російської федерації посилення
дипломатичного тиску так само говорили
про те що всі парламенти світу мають
визнати Росію країною спонсором
тероризму В дії Росії в Україні Це
очевидно що це є
геноцид проти українців і Росія має бути
викинута з усіх міжнародних організацій
зокрема із рад без ООН де вона абсолютно
незаконно займає місце До речі саме
спікер британського парламенту сьогодні
на саміті спікерів G20 заявив що не буде
підписувати спільної резолюції через те
що в цій резолюції немає засудження
агресії Російської Федерації
саме Так виглядає парламентське
лідерство саме Так виглядає лідерство
країн Ми дуже дякуємо Британії і ну
продовжуємо нашу боротьбу на
дипломатичному фронті для того щоб
Україна наша збройні сили були
сильнішими аби наблизити нашу перемогу
Ну і вже додому додому їдемо додому для
того щоби там працювати так само для
допомоги Українській армії Британія
Дякуємо за ці дні в бірмінгеми в Лондоні
за дуже важливі зустрічі в парламенті в
середовищі консервативної партії Ми
почули потужну підтримку України Ну і на
вулицях прості люди підходять до
Порошенка вітають і говорять що сьогодні
Україна викликає величезне захоплення
кожен українець який протистоїть
авторитарному режиму Путіна це буде
Україна друзі